regi Aloysius Miller jr. the third the
hall-of-famer he'll be calling final
four games in Dayton Ohio
March 19th and red joining us now
good morning reg I don't know if you you
saw this report that just came out from
Bleacher Report with Ric Bucher
apparently Jeanne bust was so upset with
rich Paul for leaking the anthony davis
trade talks that she contemplated
trading lebron james well does it mean
if it's in print it's true I'm sure
there's I'm sure that story has some
legs to it should they contemplate
training LeBron James absolutely not
it's almost like trying to trade Michael
Jordan are trying to trade Magic Johnson
but if I said you could get Anthony
Davis right now for LeBron and you're
the Lakers with and you keep the you
keep the ball and although position
you're in the same position may be worse
no you're younger and now I can get a
free agent to come in there I think I
got a better chance to get in a free
agent with Anthony Davis than I do with
LeBron and I got Anthony Davis who's
what 10 years younger than LeBron it
sets me up for the future
Anthony Davis one of the best top five
players in the game but let's face it -
he's also brittle yeah he also gets hurt
I mean you take away the groin injury
from LeBron James where he missed 18
games where at the time they were
currently sitting fourth in the Western
Conference
they missed 18 games and we all know
what happened after that barring that
injury think about his career he's
played in what 90 95 percent of his
games can you say that about Anthony
Davis
I love the talent of Anthony Davis but
does Anthony Davis get me to eight
straight NBA Finals I know coming out of
the other way out of the East I get that
but does Anthony Davis automatically get
me to the NBA Finals LeBron James does
I'm sorry no absolutely not I would not
trade LeBron James for Anthony Davis and
it makes me a better team do you know
the
the shelf-life of LeBron yeah I know
it's limited now he's 33 34 and he's
always got so many good years left but
they're only a piece or two probably two
pieces away the key is Kent LeBron and
polenka get those pieces personally I do
not think so but I don't think they can
get that with Avenue Davis as well so
why not keep the best player or let's
say he slipped listen LeBron James has
let's say Kevin Durant is taking the
mantle let's say Yanis opticool has
taken the metal okay well LeBron is
still one of the top three player in the
world yeah but I got a look at the
bigger picture here do do you think the
Lakers
will go to the Western putting do you
think they'll go to an NBA Finals well
LeBrons there if they get to the pieces
I'm talking about if they were to get
let's say hypothetically they get klay
Thompson and they're not going to get
any uh they're not gonna get Davis let's
say they get boogie cousins no klay
Thompson and they need it big they need
a good big and I just don't know what's
out there so no I don't see them going
to the NBA Finals not in the West
now if Golden State keeps that team
together which I don't know the way
they've been playing lately I don't know
what's up with the Warriors so but
there's a it's a lot more competition
out west and he knew this coming into
that talking to Reggie Miller did you
watch the Duke game last night I did do
you think knows I do you think Frank
Howard of Syracuse was trying to trip
Sian Williamson I look at this from
different angles the same angles as
everyone else again we don't know the
intent we don't know what's in a young
man's head but looking at it on film yes
yeah it did but again I don't know
intent I don't know what's in the man's
head
I really don't so you're asking me - did
he intentionally try to trip
Zion I can't answer that looking at the
film looking at the tape
I say yes Berkeley was on yesterday and
he said he would take our Jay Barrett
over Zion Williamson
that's why Charles is in Atlanta and not
working in the front office I love this
is his job is to push the needle but
he's absolutely for organizations you
need players to put fans in the seat
that's what Zion Williamson's does I
know everyone wants to say well what
position he's going to play I'll find a
position for Zion okay
I'll develop his game Zion will put
people in the stands not only at home
but on the road RJ Barrett is fantastic
he'll obviously be a lottery he might go
right behind Sion but if I have the
number one pick I'm absolutely going
with iron Williamson yeah I agree with
you like I'm not worried about this
whole well what position does he play
you know he Barkley didn't have a
position I mean there's certain guys
that just they play basketball we got
caught up in oil you're a one and you're
a two and year three and year four or
five that's all changed now and absolute
you are 100% correct Theodore
our game has evolved now where you've
got sinners who primarily shoot
three-pointers now as well as power
forwards Dirk has changed the game
because of that so you look at Dyan he
could play anywhere he want because he
can handle the basketball we know what
he can do at the defensive in if you
look at Dukes numbers while he was out
how they plummeted because he was the
last line that pack line defensively and
we know he's a unbelievable finisher in
the open court is his jump shot suspect
absolutely but that's the last thing
that's the thing that's the one thing he
can always work on we as much as the MVP
this year is going to be honest on t to
comfo how many threes has he made this
year three five seven I mean we know
that
he scores 18 points a game 18 points a
game in the paint 18 of his 29 points
are scored in the paint for Auntie took
umph oh yeah you can't tell me that
design Williamson can do that well plus
the floor is going to be spread because
there you got all these three-point
shooters so now I I have him with more
room to be able to move maneuver to get
to the hoop so it might be an advantage
to have him in today's game where the
floor is spread you know durant doesn't
shoot threes like he's comfortable with
the 18 footer
I think Zion is comfortable with that
but he can also get to the hoop with
that size that speed and that
athleticism you know I'm not worried the
year last year and was an all-star this
year and he's oh for 15 from Three's in
his career yeah
and he's an all-star and he hasn't taken
an outside shot probably since it's LSU
days okay so am I worried about Zion
Williamson and his lack of outside
shooting absolutely not I'm trying to
put people in the seats love RJ Barrett
love cam reddish but those players I
look at the G League and there's news
down there that can do what they're
doing right now you look at the G League
or and around the league you tell me how
many players are doing 360s through
their legs and finishing like Zion
Williams no the Russell Russell
Westbrook situation I know it's easy for
us on the outside to say you can't
engage with the fan like this but look
you you were a poster child for this
where you had fans who were coming after
you certainly in New York but how tough
is it when you hear something and
sometimes there's a go word that said
and you know you can't say it because we
all understand that Russ what he did and
you could be frustrated you can't
threaten fans you just can't and and you
can't threaten a woman here so I'm
surprised he got off easily at $25,000 I
think what both sides did the league
finding the rs.25000 you could be right
could have been $50 and could have been
100,000 because of the threat towards
the woman but I like the response all
by the Jazz by banning for life any
event basketball concerts whatever that
goes on in that building that this fan
is not a part of I've absolutely
absolutely heard everything under the
Sun directed at towards me towards my
teammates some racially motivated some
family I've heard it all there's been
times when I've wanted to go into the
stands and absolutely respond I under I
absolutely see where Russ is coming from
but you can't yeah you you just can't
now what I would have done is when this
guy was saying all that I would probably
told the usher from what I understand he
did to remove the guy get him out of
here and they wouldn't what I would have
done because he was on the bench I would
have walked up to the court and called
the timeout
everyone was looked at me crazy I would
have called all my guys over I'm the
captain I'm the leader of the same we're
not playing let's go to the locker room
I'm sure Carl Albert all my coaches Jack
Ram they all would looked at me crazy
like what the hell is going on this dude
this is what he said because people
backed it up this is exactly what he
said I am out of here we are out of here
until this dude is gone I guarantee you
in a nanosecond that thing would have
been handled or you go to the officials
say get them out I've done that a lot of
times I've got onto the lead official
and say the dude has crossed the line I
know you don't want me to go into the
stands and clock them and I know you
don't want the headache of that so you
better handle it or I'm gonna handle it
and most officials will get the guy out
of there or the lady out of there but
you can't respond by saying I will ask
you up when you've got camera phones and
microphones everywhere running but I get
it because I've heard it I've heard it
I've been a part of it but you can't
respond that way you let other people
handle it and if they don't handle it
you take metals it matters into your
into your own hands and the way I just
explained call a timeout and saying
we're out of here and everyone looked at
you crazy like what do you mean we're
out of here
this dude is out of here or we're back
in the locker room
Paulie brought this up yesterday Steph
Curry or Kevin Durant
right now you could only vote for one if
they stopped playing right now and you
can only vote for one for the whole
offense and I believe they're similar
age 31 who gets your vote that's very
good but Steph has changed the way we
see basketball you have to pick up Steph
Curry 50 to 55 feet even before he
crosses half-court now almost
three-quarters court because of that
range he's changed the way you play high
pick-and-rolls movement without the
basketball Kevin Durant's a freak of
nature at 611 7 feet long arms being
able to handle the basketball both are
free freaks of nature but Steph has
changed the way youth basketball is
played maybe sometimes to the detriment
every kid now thinks they can shoot
threes right no I've been think about
this when kids go see one you and I were
a kid Dan when the game started everyone
started with layups now right you know
giving your layup lines and star lives
to get warmed up you walk into a game
now kids as soon as I get onto the court
where they do they run to the
three-point line
that's not Steph necessarily his fault
because he's so good at it but it's that
he's changed it towards that because all
they see is the highlights of curry
through the legs cross back double
step-back three
yeah that was my answer to and you know
I've been accused of not appreciating
Kevin Durant I I do it's just I do I
just I think Steph Curry is somebody
that will look back on and there'll be
you know four or five players where you
say that guy came in and he was
different he changed the game that guy
came in he changed the game and Steph
Curry's certainly one of those guys yes
pulling did you have a hypothetical now
we were just talking about how tough of
a question that is there's no wrong
answer yeah by the way Steph one year
had four hundred-plus threes and another
year I mean the next year came back and
had 300 plus years my best my best year
was 221 and I believe that's when they
brought the three-point line in and this
dude is doing 250 plus two three hundred
threes a season like it's
and shooting almost you know forty to
forty three percent from three-point
line it's ridiculous what he has done I
also brought this up with Barkley where
I look at James Harden and I I do think
he's underappreciated I don't know why I
say that but I I just I marvel that he's
such a dangerous
three-point shooter beautiful stroke but
that ability to take contact and get to
the he's equally as dangerous from three
or in you know going to the hoop and
they're not many guys that you can say
that in NBA history and and I know with
the advent of you know three-point
shooting and now it's widely accepted to
take fifteen in the game but can you
think of somebody who has that ability
to be that great from that deep and then
even dunking on people taking you know
contact and I I mean it's a short list
I'm guessing with you know it is a short
list and I can't
off the top of my head think it's the
one and on top of that being left-handed
you know I think that's what sets him
apart as well but this is it
this is the uniqueness of James Harden
because from here on out especially now
that he's an MVP we're gonna start
judging him by playoff success I know
last year they got to the Conference
Finals and they lost in seven games to
the eventual champion warriors but I
don't care what he does during the
regular season this year he's certainly
one two or three and the MVP voting
again we all know about the 30-plus
games streak he had going on second two
will now that Chris Paul seems to be
healthy they're clicking things are
right I don't care about all that
because now I care about can Chris Paul
stay healthy in the playoffs which
hasn't been the case throughout his
career and can this style can this brand
of basketball where it's 25 dribbles
step-back travel three can that be a
winner and gets you to the NBA Finals
and the Western Conference versus your
nemesis a team that's you know beat you
or knocked you out of the playoffs in
the champions in the Golden State
Warriors so I'm only going to judge
about
well success now he's earned that for me
I know what he can do during the regular
season I want to see this type of
mentality scoring dominating games let's
think about and Paulie could pull this
up let's pull up his playoff numbers not
very good no I I want to see this type
of James Harden in the playoffs I'm glad
you're back we were worried about you I
was a little sick got sick after that
Portland game had a little stomach flu
but I'm back March Madness is around the
corner how great is this there's one
team that everyone's gonna be watching
obviously Zion Williamson and Duke Coach
K every kid who's gonna be able to beat
them will it be a Cinderella team to
beat them but it's wide open I mean
Kentucky could go out the first round
I mean it's Gonzaga could go out the
first round yeah I mean it's crazy it's
wide open we could have Houston we could
have Nevada teams like that could make
the final four they get hot single game
elimination spring training baseball
everyone's gearing up for the NBA up for
the NBA playoffs this is truly them on
Dan Patrick him and my dad this is the
best time of the year people wake up
wake up and I'm glad you enjoyed the
interview with your sister on undeniable
okay now I know you and I you're my boy
and I love you and I hit you and I said
this but I want everyone to know this if
you have not watched undeniable when you
interviewed Sheryl Dean it was arguably
the best interview I've seen not
necessarily cuz it was my sister but you
run out things in her because as
athletes a lot of times when we sit down
in a chair there are certain things you
want to get out there and there's
certain things you're trying to suppress
you don't want to come out you brought
everything out you brought every emotion
out and I hit you and said it was the
best interview I've ever seen someone do
on Cheryl and you you you took her you
took her there so it was fabulous I love
you you're my boy a lot of times I give
you stuff about certain things but in
terms of interviewing people and doing
your research and bringing it out
you brought it out you brought it out
Thank You wrench but I was I was
interested on how you thought I handled
it because you know it's it's delicate
because we're talking about your mom
talking about your dad she's emotional
my dad was Yuri you know look she made
you cry I know funny you don't want to
repeat the circle of life it's funny I
was at my son's he's in t-ball right
baseball and you know my dad was so hard
on on earth and I'm watching him and I
have to take a step back you know I I'm
not going to be their dad and there's
times for it there's times to be
critical but I let him do what he needs
to do what he wants he needs to find his
own path
I'll give him every instruction if he
wants it if he comes to being asked me
what but until that I can't I can't do I
can do it yeah and it's not an
indictment on my dad because that's how
most of us have become and gotten to the
level where we are now and I think Shirl
highlighted that but there's other times
when you just need to be a five and a
half year old a seven year old a ten
year old and just you know have fun glad
you're feeling better and we'll check in
with you next week Thank You reg you
know you're the best
Dennis I love y'all Martha's baby let's
do it that's a Reggie Miller for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]